Hi, Des Miles here, and if you have a problem with those nasty
blood stains, then boy to I have the product for you!
Introducing: Assassin's Cream.
Just apply it to your bloodstain, and run.
Then, whola! Good as new!
No more nasty stains that make you stick out in the crowd.
Just apply, and rub in, for an immediate long lasting effect.
Don't believe it? Just ask this satisfied customer.
I highly recommend this product. Helped me save my evening wear.
You can get Assassin's Cream right now for 20 dollars and 7 cents.
Order now and we will throw in the Assassin's Cream Brotherhood Pack.
It's enough for the whole crew. That's four times
the Assassin's Cream for the price of one!
Call the number on your screen NOW!